hello everyone and welcome back to
rotten tomatoes is wrong a podcast by
rotten tomatoes i am your host mark
ellis i am flying solo today because my
co-host jacqueline coley well what can i
give away she's on assignment i'm able
to say that the particular assignment
we're talking about today is there's a
big movie that just came out and it is
directed by a guy who i love from his
sketch comedy days and now he's
directing some pretty scary movies so
jacqueline is doing a lot of stuff with
that particular film and so she can't be
here today but i'll tell you who is
going to be here in just a couple of
minutes tim ryan our expert review
curation manager and then after tim oh
yeah by the way we have the current belt
holder in the women's division for the
wwe liv morgan is going to be joining us
she is the smackdown women's
championship belt holder and she's going
to be defending that belt this week
against i mean the formidable
competition the wwe is one thing when
you bring in folks from the ufc when you
bring in somebody like a ronda rousey it
goes to a whole other level and you can
watch it all on summerslam right here on
peacock july 30th if you happen to be
watching us on peacock hello to all of
our listeners out there as well very
excited to talk saw with liv morgan the
movie that started a franchise that some
people love some people say oh it's
gross torture porn i just got to see
soft for the very first time can you
believe i've never seen saw came out in
2004 never seen it until this very week
but it's rotten it's 51 rotten
that's according to the tomato meter 84
according to the audience course we're
going to get her saw take and probably
go a lot of different directions once we
get liv morgan here on the show in just
a couple minutes but first a couple
quick news and notes we are in the heat
of the summer this fall i'm back on the
road so you can get tickets for my
comedy tour leading up to a very special
taping event in l.a in december that's
at mark ellis dot live for all of the
cities that i will be performing at and
a huge thank you to everybody who came
to my show at san diego comic-con i love
doing the annual american comedy company
in the gaslamp district right across the
street from the comic-con convention
center uh y'all always pack that place
out and me and a lot of my friends have
fun popping up on stage and telling you
our new jokes that have a lot to do with
some nerdy stuff that you're going to be
seeing at comic con so i'll see y'all
there next year in the meantime we're
here to talk about saw and why on earth
is it rotten or maybe does it deserve to
be rotten that's what our friend tim
ryan is here to set up he's going to
tell us what the critics were saying at
the time of saul's release way back when
i don't even know if we knew if ross and
rachel were going to make it or not yet
but we knew chandler monica were a thing
and so for the darker side of
entertainment back then here's tim ryan
[Music]
it's safe to say that the three big
breakout hits of the 2004 sundance film
festival were garden state napoleon
dynamite and saw that's right before it
spawned eight sequels and generated
hundreds of millions of dollars at the
box office saw was a little indie horror
film hoping to stand out in a festival
lineup that included the dark and
disturbing likes of the machinist high
tension open water mean creek and primer
upon its release that fall saw earned
comparisons to seven more for its
thematic similarities than its technical
brilliance
that said it clearly struck a nerve with
some critics praising its clever twists
and others bemoaning its sadistic gore
saw is rotten at 51 on the tomato meter
with 188 reviews and it has an 84
audience score so what did the critics
have to say in a rotten review james
christopher of the times of london wrote
james wan's horror film saw is full of
demented twists and guilty looking
actors but the scenario is cruel enough
to make you squirm
however in a fresh review robert k elder
of the chicago tribune wrote saw is a
nasty nasty piece of business and i mean
that in the nicest possible way the
rotten tomatoes critic's consensus reads
saw ensnares audiences with a
deceptively clever plot and a myriad of
memorable nasty set pieces but its lofty
ambitions are undercut by a nihilistic
streak that feels more mean than
profound
so that's the original saw
jaclyn mark
listening to you is the opposite of
torture back to you folks all right
thank you tim and without further ado
let's get into this interview with wwe
superstar with morgan
as mentioned at the top of the show it's
a very exciting day here at rotten
tomatoes just wrong because our guests
today you know we've had some pretty
good guests over the years we've had
some very special panelists here to talk
about movies but no one ever liked this
we have liv morgan who is obviously a
champion smackdown wrestler you can
catch her on wwe summerslam which is
going to be on peacock july 30th so this
is dropping and then later on this week
we have summerslam coming up it's a very
exciting time for liv morgan welcome to
the show liv how's it going
you're prepping for summerslam and
you're taking some time out right before
that to come talk horror movies with us
of course i always have time to talk
horror movies yeah summerslam is coming
up but today
i'm all your guys oh this is great and
you're kind of the reason why i saw this
movie saw i'd never seen it before i'm a
big horror movie fan
never seen saw never seen a song movie
not a one of them
you know i here's here's the thing is
like you think about horror movies and
people love to have their little
subgenres with horror movies and and
this one always kind of flirted with the
is it torture porn is it a real horror
movie but at the end of the day
you know how would you describe so let's
say you're trying to sell somebody that
you're friends with on seeing saw for
the first time how would you describe it
to them oh like it's sick it's graphic
um
you see so much blood and gore and
but it's smart
i think that's the big thing is that it
is it's smart in a way that it's not
just there to be disgusting and violent
and bloody there's certainly that
element but you also get some real
genius behind these traps
puzzles however you want to refer to
them so we're going to get into saw in
particular the 2004 movie that is i
think a travesty being rotten on the
tomato meter at 51 but before we get
into that
your entry point into horror movies if
we can go way back when with liv morgan
do you remember like the first time you
saw a horror movie and you're like i
kind of dig what's going on here
yeah i mean i think the first thing that
i can truly remember is seeing blair
witch
but it like it it truly like terrified
me and frightened me i thought it was
real because like i remember at that
time like it was kind of being like
played off like this real footage
um so i thought it was real and so it
terrified me um i still watch it though
i don't know why i was a little sicko i
was so scared that i was like almost in
tears but i like couldn't look away oh
that's movie experience that movie
scared the crap out of okay i'll tell
you this quick story so blair witch
project it was really like the last
great rumor before the internet could
debunk stuff you know
yeah and so this movie i see this movie
poster and it's like this is the found
footage it's a true story there is a
documentary that it it's a mockumentary
but i didn't know it at the time that
aired on sci-fi network and it was like
the backstory of the blair witch keep in
mind i grew up in the in the woods of
virginia so i'm like just south of
burkinsville
and it freaked me out to the point where
i was like is is there like a way to
like is this a real thing so i really
thought it was real when i saw the movie
yeah so did i so did i and it was
terrifying like i said
like do we make a look for these kids
it's it's it's one of those types of
things too where i imagine as a wrestler
you get this too where you want
something that's going to unite the
crowd so when you're wrestling in an
arena it whether it's you know if it
doesn't really matter who the who the
face is who the heel is if there's going
to be turns during the match but you
want the crowd to be in on it and i feel
like horror movies in general are even
better than comedy movies are the best
sort of like the crowd is all in this
together is there like a movie theater
experience that you had with a horror
movie where you're like boom this is why
i love going to see the stuff in
theaters
i have to i have to think on that a bit
i remember like seeing the grudge in
theaters and everyone just
gasping and just like
you know screaming um i can't i can't
pinpoint like a unanimous moment where
everyone
had the same reaction that made me take
notice have you the grudge was one of
the big ones for me it's funny you bring
that movie up when the kid opens his
mouth and it just keeps opening you're
like what the hell yeah yeah and i
remember also like that was like one of
the few scary movies that i've seen and
also i was like younger when i watched
it so it scared
me but like having to question myself
like do i need to leave the theater like
can i sit through this um and like
having my feet up on the seat like my
feet weren't even touching the ground i
was like holding my knees and just like
genuinely questioning like can i finish
this movie
yeah those are those are the fun ones
where it's almost like a marathon it's
like an endurance trial do you have a do
you have like one movie that is your
favorite horror movie of all time or is
it blair witch or is it a saw movie like
i don't have one i wish i did i don't
have a favorite of all time like i have
ones that i constantly kind of
rewatch whether it's for like nostalgia
um but i i don't know that i have a very
favorite scary movie
i feel like the genius of saw is that it
does give us those classic horror movie
feels because you have this diabolical
genius villain so you could compare
jigsaw to like a freddy krueger or jason
voorhees but like
freddie and jason are out for revenge
like they feel like they've been wronged
this this this jigsaw guy he just loves
he just loves puzzles and he happens to
be you know with the sadomasocus doing
it but he still enjoys just the puzzles
and making people figure stuff out so
let's get in my first question to you
about saw in general in the 2004 movie
is i i have to ask everybody this on the
show it's 51
rotten on the tomato meter is rotten
tomatoes wrong about saw they're wrong
they're so wrong they're so wrong
they're really wrong what what do the
comments say why don't they
why don't they like it why is it only
51.
it's a great question because the
audience score for saw is it's uh is
it's 84 percent and so
rotten tomato score should be yeah you
see that and it's like that's what the
actual tomato meter should be i think in
a lot of people's minds because i know
that the movie was a surprise success
when it came out but you don't get to
have what seven eight sequels there's
there's prequels there's you know i'm
going to read the critics consensus of
saul to you and you let me know if you
agree with this or not okay
saw ensnares audiences with a
deceptively clever plot and a myriad of
memorable nasty set pieces but its lofty
ambitions are undercut by a nihilistic
streak that feels more mean than
profound
um
i mean it
it's it's a horror movie but it was as
mean as it was profound
that's fair i think that's fair and and
and the traps i think are what attracted
a lot of people not just to this movie
but also the sequels i think that's why
you keep going back to a saw movie
because you want to see what are the new
like clever traps that you get to
witness your first time seeing saw
though do you remember what it was like
like what did you see in the theater did
you sneak in did you see it no
i um was actually at my house it was um
i was with my mom and my brothers and we
just it was late night and we just
decided to put on saw
and so we watched it from beginning to
end and i just remember um
that plot twist i know we're not there
yet but blew me away
blew me away i was like erupted um no
one saw it coming um but yeah i was i
was so scared but i was my family so i
was okay and i was trying to play it
cool but i was like wow
i think it was the most graphic
i've ever seen maybe apart from like
hostile in that time i just was like
well they're showing everything
hostile's a good one do you come from a
family of horror movie lovers or was
this your recommendation for family no
yeah no i mean definitely wasn't my
recommendation i was i was so young i
think my my older brother
had heard it was you know good and so we
put it on and usually like you know my
mom's not usually down for scary movies
so she was for some reason
wanting to watch this night so yeah we
watched it all together
it was scary
hey props to your mom because my mom
wouldn't make it five seconds into this
movie yeah she usually doesn't like it
but for some reason she watched the
whole entire thing i think once you get
locked into like the the the sort of
crime solving aspect of this movie it
it's you can actually be if you're not a
big like blood and guts person totally
it gives you more
yeah it gives you more to work with but
i love svu so i could totally see why
actually she like watched all of song
have you ever done i've never actually
done this and and this isn't like a
question i thought of it in advance have
you ever done an escape room because i
feel like saw is the reason why we have
escape rooms yes on the internet and you
know in person where they do you know
host escape rooms i've done tons of
escape rooms
okay how does how does liv morgan do
what's your what's your weight success
rate i escape every single time all
right getting out of there
all right if you need an escape room
buddy live organization every single
time
there's the belt
there's the belt that's so funny i i
think that i would be good at solving
the puzzle i'm pretty good at tetris but
then here's the issue i have with all
these traps is that once you figure out
what's going on then you get the key and
then you have to unlock that's the
hardest part about it like when i go to
the gym i have my own lock and i still
can't get the key in on the first or
second or third time oh yeah so it's the
actual key thing see the lock
no no and so i'm like i i don't know how
to do this did you have like a favorite
a favorite trap of anybody that you see
in the first song movie did you have
like one where you're like ooh that's a
that's that's clever i have a favorite
trap of all time it's not the first one
but i think in the first one maybe
amanda's
maybe amanda's you know um
she had to kill this man
you know
find the key in his stomach
somehow find her a keyhole and she
finally gets it off right before
you know it snaps i don't know if it's
because it's kind of like the first one
that we see but also like
just the anxiety knowing like oh my gosh
she literally is running out of time and
she can't find the lock i don't know
she's very like
anxiety-inducing
hello
amanda you don't know me but
i know you
i want to play a game
here's what happens if you lose
the device you're wearing is hooked into
your upper and lower jaws
when the timer in the back goes off
your mouth will be permanently ripped
open
think of it like a
reverse stair trap
here
i'll show you
i have a dentist appointment in like a
week and like this was not the right
movie to see before
because that trap that if those who
aren't as familiar with saw i haven't
rewatched it as recent as live and i
have it's
it's this trap where it's just like this
huge steel grid that's really all over
your head but particularly your mouth
and so it's basically going to blow your
head up from the inside starting with
your teeth if you don't get it unlocked
in time and and amanda is the only
person who has survived a trap from
jigsaw to this point and so
she's sort of the the conduit and it's
like then we find out in the police
station oh she had to kill a guy just to
get the key and so
i don't know how you prosecute that way
it's like well no this guy put me in a
position where i had to kill somebody
and so that's really
the premise that we're in here with with
our with our photographer and with our
doctor and with a mysterious dead
looking guy in the middle of the room i
just love the i love horror movies that
have a simple premise like that where
it's like hey all you got to do is get
out of the room and you win but in order
to do that wow do you have to go through
some stuff so
do you have a person i i guess i'll go
back to the first time you and your
family are watching saw and you and you
see what's going on in the room do you
have a person that you're pulling for
more than the other are you like rooting
for the photographer played by lee
wennell are you rooting for the doctor
played by carrie elways did it switch at
all
i think it switched well because you
know did a good job at kind of placing
guilt
and innocence on both characters like
you know throughout so you were back and
i was back and forth throughout the
whole thing because you'd find out
something about someone and you know
then you're kind of swaying um
do we talk like i guess we could talk
the movie right because like i guess
everyone has seen it that has watched
this but i'm not
ugly right now like do i say spoilers
our audience has already been warned
about spoilers you go ahead and get as
deep into this movie as you want yeah so
i felt
for some reason more bad when adam died
even though you know gordon ended up
escaping you know and even though he had
family for some reason i think when i
look back i felt i felt more sorry for
adam
i don't know why
i mean adam is your photographer and
he's just kind of the the the schlub
that gets roped into this because you
need an opponent and so
you know he's just he's paid to go take
pictures but
i think the other fun thing about this
movie in retrospect is seeing that the
guy um who played benjamin linus in lost
is is in the film here and he's
he's like the weirdo who works at the
hospital but he's also being used by
jigsaw to is sort of i guess for lack of
a better word recruit these villains
he's played by michael emerson zepp is
the character and so
that also was was a really interesting
thing i didn't know about saw because
you just hear that it's all these like
inventive traps and stuff i didn't
realize that we got the family involved
too and they were kidnapped in another
room yeah
yeah yeah it was it was loaded um it
just got crazier as you watch like more
plot twists more
more at stake more to fight for
you know what i always think about
though is like how long was adam in the
tub in the beginning before i woke up
that's a great very freaking he's like
waking up out of the water and i'm
always like how long was he
submerged for did they just put him
there because you know like over like
three minutes you know it's like brain
damage so he's like how long how long
was he in this water for yeah he's
definitely gonna be pruning he's gonna
have all the wrinkles on his fingertips
when he gets out of there and then he
gets out of the bath only to have to
reach deep into a toilet to look for a
mysterious garbage bag that we think
only has two saws in there and
this is why i'm i'm kind of a [ __ ] i
should point this out to you when i'm
watching horror movies or like whodunits
i never know the twists i never see them
coming i just take everything at face
value
so when he takes the two saws out of the
bag i'm like ah that's the name of the
movie and then he's got this weird look
right before he tosses the rest of the
garbage bag into the tub and i'm like is
there something else in that bag and
then i forgot it i totally forgot it
until the pictures come out and so he is
the one who's been taking pictures of
kerry always who may or may not be
cheating on his wife and those are also
in the garbage bag
also um i'm like forgetting
when he reached into the toilet he did
it for no reason right because it was in
the tank it was in the tank yeah he went
all the way down into the guts of the
toilet yeah it was disgusting and then
just to realize it was in the tank so
funny
i think my favorite um sort of trap is i
do love that the jigsaw gave them each a
saw and they're like just trying in vain
to like saw and then gary carrie always
character has the realization that oh
yeah we're supposed to saw off
our
feet
and
i don't know that i could ever get
myself to that point liv i think i might
just be content to die in the room
instead of sawing i don't i you know
that's the fun thing about these movies
is it puts you in that room and you say
what would i do to survive yeah that's
something i contemplated with too i'm
like you know would i have sawed off my
own foot and i truly don't know either i
might have just been like take me i
might have just been okay to die as well
i don't know that i would have saw it
off my foot but also i guess like you
know the pressure of the clock ticking
down
you know maybe those last couple seconds
i just was like ah you know and maybe
maybe i would do it i don't know
oof
the family aspect i think maybe because
like he's trying to sell his foot off to
get out to like save his wife and kid if
somebody had done that to me and and
then they posted like a picture of of my
dog molly the wonder dog like in another
room i'd be like yeah i'd stop my own
foot off for maui yeah of course you
know like if you have the right bait or
the right reasoning you know like i said
but yeah i mean family if you have you
know a picture of my dog or my chicken
cows my mom my brothers you know my
sisters i'm i'm i'll fall off i'll off
anything you're chicken and your cat
you're you're you're losing an appendage
off my foot for my chickens okay all
right this is this is new information we
are we're learning how far liv is
willing to go for chickens and
i mean they really are the most innocent
of all of us so they're still better
so so innocent i would help them out i'd
have to
so
the twist that really shook me and again
i saw this movie for the first time this
week
is yeah we're just like we're we're in
this room and
we feel like over an hour into this
movie we know what we're in for now it's
like it's it's doctor versus
photographer it's are we going to team
up is there a way to team up is one of
us gonna have to kill the other person
and then we find out where's jigsaw he's
been in the middle of the room
pretending to be dead the whole time my
mind exploded not one part of me thought
that that was
even a possibility
not even once um i was so
so so baffled i remember thinking like
i remember a winding like do we see them
breathing like you know did they let us
know and we just didn't notice it
because he was looking at the dead man
in the middle of the floor i remember
rewinding like looking for breath
or just any kind of body movement um i
was it was it was stunning it was i
thought the smartest thing i've ever
seen in my whole entire life i was like
wow genuinely
shocked stunned they got us
what a plot twist
it's a very interesting person his name
is john has an inoperable frontal lobe
tumor i'm sick from the disease eating
away at me inside sounds like our friend
i'm sick of people who don't appreciate
their blessings looks like our guy likes
to book himself fighting our seats to
his own sick like
hello
poor amanda
gordon i want to play a game
the commitment to the gag that's always
the hardest thing like when i back in
another life year decades ago i was on i
was on mtv's punk and like the hardest
thing to do when you're trying to punk
somebody is you're just there waiting on
even before they show up to set you're
just like oh
it's like you know when you're like when
you're a kid and you're hiding behind a
door to like scare your friend like
you're hiding behind there for like 10
seconds yeah
all day and in this guy's case you're
going to lay in a bunch of blood you got
to lie with all these like prosthetics
on to make it look like you just blew
your hands you know trying to get the
recorder out of his hands you know
they're trying to get this you know like
he's having to lay there as they're like
whipping him with shirts and stuff
trying to retrieve stuff
okay well let me ask you this because
again this might just be me as a global
viewer so there's a scene where we think
that adam the photographer is maybe
dying because he smoked a poisonous
cigarette even though it says in the box
and it shows the audience hey the
cigarettes are not poisonous don't worry
about it so he gets a cigarette and he
lights it and he kind of fakes dying
so that the purveyors of the game will
think that he's dead that gordon killed
him and then gordon can escape um
i thought he was dead i thought he was
that too i thought he was that too i
was like that's it
yeah i was like oh that was easy yeah it
was crazy i i'm trying to um i feel like
i need to watch that back actually well
it's funny because like i'm watching and
i know lee wannel who who the actor who
plays him is more known for directing
movies he went on to do an insidious
film he did upgrade he uh did the
invisible man so
any any i think he co-wrote saw and he's
and he's an accomplished writer of the
genre of movies in general too so i'm
watching him act and i'm like yeah this
is a good it's not the best death i've
ever seen and then
they turn the electrocution on it's like
oh he was never dead yeah yeah yeah but
it was fake dud
i've done it
i've killed him with the poison just
like you want
now where's my family
where are they
[Music]
[Music]
i i just got electrocuted
jesus that was our way out
did you hear what i said get this thing
off me
get up stop acting the other aspect of
saw that that i think locks people in
and maybe this is the aspect for people
to follow who aren't necessarily into
the the visceral violence as much is
watching the detective work of danny
glover's character detective tap and his
partner detective singh as they're
piecing together because like danny
glover becomes obsessed with this
with what's going on here because he's
got you know now he's got skin in the
game because he almost lost his light to
this guy i was so rooting for them when
they find out where jigsaw's sort of
hideaway is and then we think we got
jigsaw but this guy thought of
everything the shotgun trap that
emotionally moved me when we get
detective singh who's another lost
veteran who just walks into a bunch of
shotguns i felt so bad for that guy yeah
i was unfortunate they were definitely
trying their hardest
you thought that they were going to save
the day you thought they were going to
be the heroes and walk in on the room
and find the boys before anything
happened and then
they just get murdered and you're just
like oh no then you really just think
they're done for it all right so as
somebody who has not seen any of the
song sequels yet i'm looking forward to
watching them you're already telling me
that there's even better traps in the
future
our engineer brian said that he likes uh
saw two the best oh that would say two
is so good she's so good i think like i
like one
as um i think i like one the most just
because it's like the original you know
it's like the blueprint two is great
though i think two is my favorite out of
the rest of um the sequels did you stick
with all the sequels or did you drop off
the sawtrain at some point i dropped off
at like four
you're out
i don't know about like four
yeah i mean
they do a good job at like you know
keeping the thread you know but um i
just dropped off that four did they kill
a chicken or a cow in there and that's
why you were out i don't wanna
but some people die
you know which changes things okay no i
here's the thing i don't really care
about spoilers with this the movie that
i was excited to see because i love
chris rock so much is spiral which is
like it's like
haven't watched spiral okay all right
well then
we'll we'll both do our homework and
watch spiral and then we'll have you
back um
at some point in the future so we can
talk about spiral because every one of
these movies is rotten on the tomato
meter and it's interesting because
they go down in descending order there's
like great character work
it's i mean you talk about
you talking about it
is one that feels justified yes and it's
it's an actor's dream to be able to get
just you don't have to do like a lot of
moving around you just have to like be
in a room and you just have to act your
ass off act like your life's at stake
act like you're cutting your arm off to
save your prized rooster or whatever's
on the phone that's like so interesting
about the movie i mean obviously there's
like um different settings but majority
it's just in that room and i feel like
to hold a film
in one single location with just
three i mean three actors once dead
and to hold the audience's attention and
to keep them watching when it's just so
simple and kind of like bare bones like
that i think that's impressive
yeah and i think my favorite trap out of
out of all the ones that we saw in the
first movie i love the barbed wire one
just because barbed wire has always
scared me
as a kid and you know i mean i've seen
wrestlers
i've seen wrestlers deal with barbed
wire before and and it looks like
you know i'm a i'm a i'm a fan of the
sport of wrestling and i've seen the
movie the wrestler and to see what
actually like the actual stuff y'all put
your bodies through is not just for show
there's like real pain being inflicted
and barbed wire seems like the worst
part of it i've never
had anything to do barbed wire so i
can't really speak from that experience
but yeah i mean i can imagine
um i mean i have barbed wire barbed wire
like starting my farm you know and
sometimes when i
get a pick of that i'm like
so i can imagine you know um that trap
and having to literally crawl through
and walk through the barbed wire we need
to barbed wire for the chip we got to
protect the chickens is is the point of
this show um we gotta keep on we gotta
keep them in the in the coop in the in
the land area
um i think that's why that trap is so
scary though is because it's like it's
not like not everyone knows what's you
know having this helmet that's literally
going to rip your jaw off feels like not
everyone knows that bob warrior feels
like but everyone knows what it is you
know everyone knows what it's for yeah
and so a little bit more i guess close
to home a little bit more like relatable
than the other
kills i guess in
one like two has a really good one like
that too i want you to go ahead and
spoil it for me what's your favorite
kill in saw two
oof okay okay okay so amanda pretty much
oh i don't want to tell you okay oh no
it's poor amanda yeah yeah okay so she
gets thrown into this pit
of
needles
so this needle is full of i mean this
pit is full of needles like hundreds and
hundreds of needles one has an antidote
and i think one has like a lethal
injection where you know if you confuse
it you're gonna die but pretty much
she's dropping to this pit of
this like ten foot pit of
hundreds and hundreds of needles and
she's just having to
scoop through them she's getting needles
all over her body and it's like one of
those things that's like we've all
gotten a shot before like we know what
that feels like so imagine being
submerged
in this pit and you're having to dig
your way
to find
the right syringe that has the right
antidote and
it's just so graphic and i saw that in
theaters actually and i remember
everyone in the audience just like kind
of just crunching and like going and
eyeing because it's like uncomfortable
to watch all right this is maybe the
most important recommendation i have for
you because i do want to ask you about
um about your background how you got
into wrestling real quick too but but
the biggest question is horror movies
are great to see in movie theaters for
two reasons one because you have like
the whole crowd with you and you're all
reacting together but two i'm the kind
of guy that i walk into a movie theater
and it doesn't matter how full i am i
could just be coming from a three five
seven course meal
don't get me started
i still need the popcorn live i still
need it i need the popcorn i need the
cookie dough bites i need the mix and
the popcorn
um that's your mix
yeah oh i'm 100 always gonna get cookie
dough bites cookie dough bites in the
popcorn and that way it kind of melts
and mixes
you know between the butter and the
melted chocolate but it's like most fire
combination ever it's like the salty and
the sweet and the chocolate and the
butter it's so good i'm trying it i got
to try that you have to or or like a
bunch of crunch works i don't like it
with snow cops i wouldn't do snow carbs
i'd do bunch of crunch or the cookie
dough bites obviously you know get a
photo with that um i think i'm gonna see
a black phone tonight i think i might go
and see black phone in the theaters
tonight have you watched it yet i have
not seen the black phone yet but
got like amazing amazing reviews and so
i was like oh maybe i'll go see that
tonight
yeah there's some saw dna there too
because you know you have like these
kids that are trapped in a room and like
the phone rings you're not supposed to
answer it but you got this weirdo who's
kind of torturing you for nefarious
purposes so
if you'll appease me i want you to try
this when you go see the black phone
tonight is it sounded disgusting to me
because i had heard of the bunch of
crunchy popcorn i had heard of milk duds
and popcorn seemed like the like that's
how everybody discovered chocolate in
popcorn first was milk
and then because the caramel gets all it
gets a little too gooey for me here's
the hack is try sour patch kids in
popcorn i knew that's what you're going
to say for some reason i knew
um
i could already taste it um i i could
understand it maybe
get a large popcorn and do your cookie
dough then just get like a small one for
the side and just try some sour patch
kids in there wonderful
better than you thought
yeah it blew me away well i mean you
can't be in that stuff all the time i
imagine if you are a professional
athlete as you are not only
a uh a warrior in the ring but you i
mean we're talking about wwe champion
here stuff so when you got into
wrestling what was the sort of the
conduit that hooked you into hey this is
something that i want to try yeah i grew
up a lifelong fan since i was i'm five
years old i remember the first time i
watched wwe i just instantly fell in
love with it and it was kind of like my
escape you know from reality so i just
fully like immersed myself into it so i
grew up a fan
and then i um was working at hooters
and a wrestler had walked in and because
i was a lifelong fan i recognized who
they were and i was like i want to
wrestle and so they were like all right
here's this trainer he has some
connections with wwe
um if he thinks you know
you're athletic enough then you know
maybe he'll pass along your information
so there was no promises so then i went
and i met this trainer and um he his
name is john franco he owns his own gym
in new jersey he only trains like
professional athletes so i walked in and
he's putting like his nfl boys through
this crazy workout and i'm just like
showing up in like sweatpants i don't
even have workout clothes i've never
worked out a day in my life oh so you
didn't have like a big history in
athletics to that point no i i had done
cheerleading in high school and
competitive cheerleading but um that was
about it and so like yeah i'm the girl
that wants to wrestle and he just kind
of looked at me and was like okay hop in
and so i'm just like you know training
with the boys and um
after about like four days he thought
that um i kind of held my own pretty
well and so he was like all right i'll
train you
and we'll prepare you for this wwe
tryout so um i train with him for six
months um about five days a week and
then my tryout came and i was just so
prepared because you know kind of knew
the ins and outs of what
was expected cardio wise and just you
know workout wise what would we be doing
kind of at the tryout so i was so
prepared and um i wanted it more than i
wanted to breathe and so i was fortunate
enough to leave there with the contract
that's amazing what a sort of like
underdog story of of you getting into
the wwe but then like as we all know
from being fans of watching it it really
you you pass those tryouts and stuff but
then the real audition is in front of
the fans right it's like whether you get
over or not so when you're introduced
for the first time in front of like a
huge throng like like in a stadium an
arena full of people what's that feeling
like um you kind of just hope for the
best i mean you have your good guys and
you have your bad guys everyone portrays
something different and they say like
you know the best character is just like
an extended version of yourself so if
you're usually at like a six or seven
dial it up to like 12 13 14 15. you know
and so um i mean i think it kind of
varies case by case i think you know
being a good guy
it's always harder to make people love
you than it kind of is to make people
hate you it's very easy to um
call the crowd names and get booze but
to get like genuine
cheers because they're happy for you or
because they like you it's a lot harder
um so yeah it's nerve-wracking to go out
into front of hundreds of thousands of
people and just um hope you get one at
the other you just want a reaction
honestly no reaction is the worst
reaction um you you'd rather take boost
all days than just like a silent crowd
yeah you you don't you definitely don't
want like the polite golf claps when
when you're out there in front of a
bunch no i mean at least that's
something honestly but when it's just
like
cricket you know it's just like ah
it seems like somebody like you might
just lean on horror movies
as sort of an escape where it's like i i
don't have to think about any of the
pressure that's that i'm under as a
professional athlete in this world i
just get to go watch people and maybe
it's those simplistic movies like saw
where it's there aren't a lot of set
pieces it's just hey i just get to watch
these people fight for their lives and
it kind of takes me out of the box that
i'm currently in yeah i love to feel you
know i love to feel and um scary horror
always makes me feel i'm always i'm
always scared
i'm always scared watching movies you
know horror movies then when i'm at my
house and i'm like oh my gosh i'm here
alone do i lock the doors you know like
i kind of live for that like adrenaline
but knowing you're safe you know so i
love to put on a horror movie and be so
scared out of my mind but
knowing it's okay because in reality i'm
safe like i love
that kind of adrenaline spike um and
also i just
i i like to look into kind of um
kind of what i said before like i feel
like the best villains are
they feel like they're justified you
know jigsaw felt so totally 100
justified in
potentially killing
dozens of people because
he thought that you know them
being ungrateful for their life was like
the biggest sin so in his mind he's like
thinks he's really helping these people
giving them a second look at life and so
just that's interesting to me too just
kind of the brain work of like what
makes them tick i'll give you that i
mean i i think at the end of the day
jigsaw is a pretty terrible person but
oh no i'm not yeah i'm not i'm not oh i
know yeah i i know you're not like
justice for jigsaw but i think
i think he's cut from a higher cloth i
would say so if there is a hell and you
go to like different like levels of it i
think like freddy and jason and michael
myers are like way down in the seventh
level jake saw maybe kicking around the
fifth or sixth level yeah yeah i could
see that you know he's not just well
it's all pointless really at the end of
the day but in his mind he's not just
killing force or like you know
chucky or freddy or jason or like you
know
i mean even leprechaun he's still a
little bit justified he's like you saw
my gold or where's my gold you know
might be the hero of that of that
franchise my gosh leprechaun used to
scare the crap i was so scared of
leprechauns so so so scared of
leprechaun i don't know why i was most
scared of leprechaun and chucky and
they're both just like tiny but that's
what made me scared
i'm you're totally right i'll tell you
why because they're things that live in
your room like nobody's inviting freddy
into their house but like you already
have evil looking dolls in your room and
so
you know that i think that's that's why
toy story to me is a horror movie
franchise it's just a bunch of sentient
toys that come to life
the bear in toy story three the evil
teddy bear that's the evils anything and
also in two what was his name the
into the um well you had the you had
that kid sid who had like the uh that
was it was part one but in part two with
jesse and they introduced bullseye what
do they call him the
he has like the white mustache i gotta
look this up toy story two
oh i found him hold on what's his name
stinky pete but he's called something
stinky pete the prospector the
prospector
yes there he is i knew something i'm
like the health inspector but no the
prospector he's the biggest heal of all
time biggest hill of all time all right
so
in liv morgan's ranking of the all-time
great horror movie villains stinky pete
the prospector is up there with
your your jigsaws your leprechauns your
chuckies of the world um liv it's been
an absolute treat getting to have you on
the show and getting to just talk really
all things horror movies horror movie
villains um
i know you're going to see black phone
tonight so we'll talk about black phone
later that's like 83 percent on the
tomato meter so that's oh everyone's
raving about it some people have seen it
like three times and just like you got
to go see us i'm like okay i've got to
go some black phone so let us know how
that goes yeah i haven't seen a scary
movie in the theaters in a long time to
you okay
okay so i'm gonna go ahead and give you
uh do you have another movie that you
want to recommend to everybody who's
listening right now it could be any
genre just like a movie that you you're
like oh everybody should go check this
out oh okay i got a good one for you
while you're thinking about it so um
nobody's pretty good nobody with bob
odenkirk yeah
i was just tweeting about this movie
last night because no spoilers here but
nobody's really i've seen it and i want
more nobody movies yeah it's really good
it was like different um i don't know
why that's the first one that popped my
mind but um it definitely left like an
impression on me i like nobody a lot it
was awesome and my recommendation for
you because lee wannel who plays adam in
saw directed upgrade have you seen
upgrade yet no is that new it's it's a
couple years old now but it it was sort
of like under the radar but it's like
sort of like a superhero meets like
science fiction a little bit of horror
element in there really really cool how
do you watch the boys i love the boys oh
my gosh the boys i'm obsessed with the
boys so good
yeah
i saw it i saw i promised let you get
out here after this now this has just
been a great long long winding
conversation the i saw a fan some sort
of fan art that was the back of
homelander and he's looking at all of
the villains in the marvel cinematic
universe like thanos and stuff so do you
think can they cross over is that the
same or different i it's it's i don't
think it'll ever happen in a million
years but wow would i pay to see it so i
know i i don't really get a topic i mean
it's a topic that we're talking about
now but let me just get this out okay so
i've watched marvel here and there right
um
throughout the years growing up but it
it didn't really make sense to me like i
remember watching spider-man
um that the first one that introduced
tom holland a spider-man i remember
seeing that in theater and kind of
watching nothing else before that being
so confused that like the crossovers the
avengers it was very confusing to me i
liked the film but i hadn't watched any
of the previous movies so it was
confusing so a couple months ago
maybe like two three months ago i
decided i'm gonna watch every single
marble
in order and so i've been watching every
single marble in order and i'm like so
obsessed i think the last thing i just
watched um
was ant-man and the boss
um
[Music]
i think it's incredible incredible
completely changed my mind of like
marvel and superheroes and then so um i
took a break to watch the boys and so i
just binged the boys and i'm like wow
this is so incredible i would die for a
marvel and the boys cross over
incredible homelander is
maybe he's the worst he might be yeah he
might be up there with stinky pete the
prospector yeah
poor homelander i feel bad for him but
he's terrible he's the worst but he's
anthony starr's so good at playing that
character so amazing i don't think i've
ever seen
acting so great he just i feel like he
just is like on cue on command cries
laughs
you see his emotions so clearly he does
such a good job of just letting you know
what he feels
with no words is incredible he wears it
on his sleeve and uh i don't think that
we're going to see you live morgan this
week on summerslam which you can catch
on peacock july 30th wearing a
homelander costume she's way too pure
for that but is there any chance we see
you walk out with some barbed wire uh
maybe actually no i can't i'll get
disqualified i'll get qualified um i
need to beat ronda rousey fair and
square so no barbed wire
maybe maybe next time maybe next time
well hey the whole gang here all of our
fresh ketchup crew fans of rotten
tomatoes is wrong are in your corner so
have a great time at summerslam um do do
the lord's work and i'll tell you what
we'll make sure the chickens are
protected so you can feel safe and just
get out there in the ring and and
wrestle your heart out okay
thank you thank you so much 51 huh so
only got 51 that's that's insane
sometimes when we talk about movies on
this show that tomato meter has a
tendency to go up if we're if we're
really stumping for a movie
so
everybody
it deserves at least a 72. all you
critics out there get it up to 72.
that's pro liv morgan and uh
if you've ever seen her wrestle trust me
you want to make her happy okay you do
not want to get on the wrong side of liv
morgan
uh once again you can catch her on
july 30th is summerslam big wwe event
this summer time and you can catch it
right here on peacock live morgan i
can't wait to talk black phone with you
or spiral or upgrade so uh have a great
time this week and uh we'll catch up
soon okay all right thank you have a
good day
[Music]
oh this is so great we set out to talk
about saw and we ended up getting
everything from toy story 2
to the boys how do we get there i mean
you would it was almost like a jigsaw
puzzle the way that we weaved in and out
of horror movies versus what to put on
popcorn versus wrestling talk really
interesting to get lip morgan's
background and every time we get to have
a wrestler on the show it makes me want
to watch whatever they're doing next
whatever the big next event is and like
i've been telling you already peacock
july 30th that's where summerslam takes
place and you can watch liv morgan
emperor will she come out with barbed
wire probably not a homelander cape
probably not but hey that's why you
watch wrestling because you never know
so in the meantime that's going to do it
for us here today at rotten tomatoes is
wrong friendly reminder you can email us
anytime if you have a movie that you
want us to talk about coming up you have
thoughts on an episode that we just
covered about a particular movie hit us
up rt is wrong at
rottentomatoes.com subscribe rate review
all that good stuff and we never let you
go without a tease about what you're
gonna hear and see next week on the show
and this is one that we've had in the
wish list for a long time the suggestion
box has been filled to the brim with
this particular movie and it's very
goofy it's a goofy movie we're finally
getting a chance to talk about it some a
hundred and whatever episodes deep into
the show we get to talk about a goofy
movie with a very special guest who has
a very special connection to molly the
wonder dog
who is also maybe related to goofy i
don't know how all that stuff works but
it's gonna be a canine tastic episode of
rotten tomatoes is wrong next week on
the show so tune in for that in the
meantime
thanks for watching this episode or
listening to this episode i'm mark ellis
for jacqueline kohler brian perez
producee lucy with morgan our special
guest molly the wonder dog and everyone
else here at rotten tomatoes thank you
and um no i do not want to play a game
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you